hello ladies it's finally time for the
video you've all been waiting for
no all right so that didn't work out
sorry ladies but I just wanted to take a
moment to reintroduce myself my name is
markiplier but that's just my handle my
full name is Mark Fischbach I'm a
biomedical engineering student from the
University of Cincinnati and I'm
introducing myself again because I
realized that the more subscribers I get
the more people that see my videos who
don't have any idea of who I am and why
I do this YouTube thing and to really
get an idea of why I do this you have to
go back in year last year was one of the
worst years of my life and I'm not even
exaggerating like that I was in a
terrible relationship I got kicked out
of house I had not been dekhta me where
they then found a tumor a ganglion
neuroma in my adrenal pen if you're
curious and it just all culminated into
a year where I didn't know what I was
going to do or why I was doing it so
flash forward to this year where in
April I finally started a YouTube
channel just on a whim I didn't even
really see it going anywhere I just did
it because I thought it'd be fun and my
first subscriber was actually just a
best friend of mine who I you know I
don't even think she really watched my
videos I think she was trying to support
me which was great anyway but then they
just spawned into something bigger than
I could possibly imagine going from
April into June losing my first channel
and then building it back up from almost
nothing again all the way to 10,000 now
and it's rocketing pass it is an
outrageous feeling it's incredible it's
why I get up in the morning I may be
studying biomedical engineering and
school but I don't think that's what I
want to do
my life anymore I love to get up and
entertain you guys I love to do this
every day I love every opportunity I
have to make videos it's just tickles me
that I can do this and for you guys but
I want you to realize that the more
subscribers I get I don't ever plan to
lose focus on why I'm here
the reason I care so much about building
up a community is because I know that we
can do amazing things together the two
thousand people who stood with me when I
first hit my charity livestream did an
amazing job raising money we raised over
$2,000 for child's play just think what
we could do with ten thousand just think
what we could do with a hundred thousand
even a million the amount of change that
we can make with a million people would
be outrageous and make no mistake I have
big goals for this channel but I'm not
in this for the fame I'm not in this for
the money I don't care about those
things what I care about is entertaining
you guys and that's the reason
that's the reason I do this everyday
that's why I want to keep them every day
I never want to stop doing this I'm
almost positive now that in some way
entertainment is always going to be a
big part of my life which is why I
always advocated building a community
and I want you guys to feel like you're
part of it and if there's any reason why
you guys should share my videos or tell
other people about my channel Berg tell
anyone that I'm a moderately funny guy
on YouTube is because I'm never going to
lose sight of where I started and how I
started going from the worst year of my
life into now the best year of my life
where I found purpose and I found a
reason to live
it's incredible fuel so I just wanted to
take a moment to really thank thank all
of you for doing everything you can to
help make this something big because I
know that with more people we can do
bigger and better things every day so
thank you all so much for watching each
of my videos I can't thank you enough
but thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye-bye